la parole est maintenant à françois noël
buffet pour le groupe de l'union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je serai sans doute un peu
moins consensuel que ce que l'on vient
d'entendre en période de crise et de
croissance atone il n'y a que deux
leviers naturellement pour réduire le
déficit public augmenter les recettes
bien sûr mais surtout diminuer les
dépenses
tous les rapports non partisan que ce
soit ceux de la cour des comptes de la
commission européenne de l'inspection
générale des finances explique avec une
grande clarté que l'effort doit
essentiellement portés sur la dépense
publique à hauteur de 50 % au minimum
pourtant pourtant vous faites le choix
en 2012 et 2013 de stabiliser dépenses
publiques à 56 3% du produit intérieur
brut et de ne commencer les efforts
d'économie qu'en 2014 seulement comme
s'il n'y avait pas urgence d'ailleurs je
note que c'est à ces dates seulement
aussi que vous ferez des marais
l'augmentation de tva que vous venez de
décider
dans le même temps vous fait exploser le
taux de prélèvements obligatoires de
pratiquement un point et demi de pib
soit 30 milliards d'euros d'impôts
supplémentaires ne peut non seulement
pas sur les grandes fortunes ou les
grandes entreprises mais impactant
également très fortement la classe
moyenne et les petites et moyennes
entreprises c'est monsieur le ministre
un matraquage fiscal
personne ne se trompe et tout le monde
le dit toute la presse le 10 qui la
résultante directe du faible efforts
consentis sur la dépense va engendrer
des effets récessifs baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et donc de la consommation
fragilisation des entreprises est
évidemment baisse des investissements
tous les leviers de croissance seront
donc impacter risquant ainsi de
compromettre notre retour aux 3% en 2013
ma question monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez sans doute bien évidemment
comprise depuis longtemps et les simples
sachant qu'en 2014 il sera peut-être
déjà trop tard quelle logique économique
sous entend le choix du gouvernement de
ne pas diminuer la dépense publique dès
maintenant
merci chers collègues ministres avaient
la parole
monsieur le sénateur votre question est
incontestablement moins consensuel je ne
suis pas sûr qu'elle soit plus lucides
ou pertinentes pour autant j'avais forcé
de vous en convaincre
d'abord entre 2002 et 2007 je vous fait
observer que l'évolution de la dépense
publique en moyenne et chaque année et
je pense avec votre approbation puisque
vous étiez dans la majorité à l'époque a
été de 2 7% entre 2007 et 2012 vous
étiez toujours dans la majorité cette
évolution la dépense publique a été de
1,3 pour cent dans la programmation des
finances publiques que nous soumettons
au parlement ce gouvernement auquel
j'appartiens se propose une évolution la
dépense publique en moyenne et chaque
année de 0,7 pour cent en fait ce sera
probablement 0,6 nous faisons donc
beaucoup mieux que vous entre 2002 et
2007 et mieux que vous entre 2007 et
2012 les éléments d'appréciation que je
vous ai cités en atteste erreur
également je me permets de le signaler
quand vous indiquer que nous attendrions
2014 pour maîtriser la dépense publique
non monsieur le sénateur cdh et l'année
prochaine puisque c'est dès l'année
prochaine que nous soumettons l'état à
la norme du zéro valeur hors
naturellement le champ de des pensions
et du service de la dette du zéro valeur
dont me semble-t-il un ministre que vous
souteniez il y a de cela quelques mois
ou années indiqué que c'était
probablement une des choses le plus dur
les plus durs que l'état ait jamais
réussi à faire il me semble qu'à voir
approuvée à l'époque ce ministre vous
deviez en être supposerait à tout le
moins de ne pas condamner d'autres qui
pourtant mettre en oeuvre cette
politique encore que de façon différente
car probablement de façon plus juste et
équilibrée entre les différentes
administrations
mais il est vrai que dès lors qu'il
s'agit de maîtriser la dépense publique
seul l'état le petit pour voir il faut
également un effort de la protection
sociale c'est le cas pour l'ondam qui
fixait à 2,7 pour cent permet une
économie en tendance de 2,5 milliards
d'euros c'est peut-être vrai aussi pour
les collectivités locales et comme je
vous vois extrêmement attentifs et
soucieux de l'évolution à dépenses
publiques je ne doute pas que lorsqu'il
s'agira de demander un effort aux
collectivités locales le gouvernement
pourra compter sur votre soutien
si un buffet sur ce dernier point je ne
crois pas avoir de leçon à recevoir
mais je constate que dans la région
rhône-alpes la région rhône-alpes
augmenter considérablement les impôts
sont se poser quelques questions que ce
soit et que le président la communauté
urbaine actuelle rechigne beaucoup à
être solidaires avec les demandes de
l'état en la matière je vous invite
d'avoir ses déclarations récentes par
ailleurs nous avons un défaut et un
désaccord profond c'est que vous tous
vos calculs sont fondés sur l'existence
d'une croissance qui n'existera pas
l'année prochaine d'un respect des 3%
que nous n'aurons pas et par ailleurs
les premiers signes de votre
gouvernement n'ont pas été de réduire la
dépense publique mais plutôt de la
conforter en engageant de nouveau des
nombre de fonctionnaires cette fois ci
pour une durée pérenne nous avons
effectivement monsieur ministre et vous
avez raison des points de vue différents
mais les actions en tous les cas sont
également différentes et vos choix ne
sont pas les nôtres la gauche a toujours
eu la même position on dépense de toute
façon au mieux on stabilise en tous les
cas on augmente les impôts et ça c'est
une réussite on peut que vous en
féliciter merci